how are you Thomas rich I am great
thanks for having me you are not on
speakerphone I know you know and I
appreciate that you speakerphone me for
what the first two or three
conversations we had right I was a Power
Move Thomas it was a bit yeah I feel bad
about it and I will never live it down
and anytime anyone does that a footnote
you so at least you're getting some
advertising on that IQ I appreciate that
that's one of the things you picked up
from Belichick right from back in it no
I know I didn't die that was of my own
no killings you're on Bluetooth right
around fingertips right now so Thomas
what what you frequently join our
program at points of the NFL calendar
outside of the playing season what what
does a general manager do right here in
the middle of June what is part of your
your role right now well you know we're
right in the middle of minicamp today so
this is kind of the final throes of this
season it's been a really long season as
you know we'll take it any day right I
was a it's it's it's a it's a challenge
adjusting when you've been in the
Superbowl right any of those people who
have been in it of course they realized
that so it's been a long season dan is
so high you know he's such an upbeat guy
so competitive so fiery that this
building has not really come down from
when we finished the Super Bowl to
free-agency in the draft it's been busy
here so we're all looking forward to the
last practice and getting out and taking
a little bit of R&R before we can get
back here and be be fired up for the
season and again this is the part of the
year where everyone takes a are you
taking an actual vacation like an actual
not doing anything with football
vacation
Tom I will like I think my biggest thing
right now is focused on trying to get
out to Colorado a little bit as you know
that's I spent a lot of time out there
when I can I still have a home out in
Boulder and and really enjoy it I'd get
out the mountains quite a bit it's good
for me I need I need my head to be
cleared you know I love getting on my
bike and I love hike and do a little bit
of rock climbing although I'm not
supposed to share that right it's
probably in my contract somewhere where
I should do that hazardous job I don't
know if that's in the GM rider I don't
think that's in the rider of a general
manager contract office that's right I
mean I've read ask me about I have a
motorcycle actually I hate to say that
but I was
I was at a speaking engagement the other
day and it came up and I thought okay
that's all I need Arthur to renege on on
the contract because I'm out on my
harley-davidson or something I'm not the
best thing to be doing now it was an
interesting week there in Atlanta where
there was a ceremony for rowdy white and
Michael Vick had I told you back in the
throes of when everything was going down
with Vic and the dog fighting in and
what was going on with the organization
that that that mr. blank would welcome
Michael Vick back to thee to the
organization in a way where they fed him
what would you have said about that
Tomas well I think as you know we came
in here that was when Smitty and I came
in we were told to clean things up so of
course that would have been a surprise
to me in it you know but time heals
right and Arthur is obviously a very
classy gentleman and very as you know
he's a very soulful guy and he he's he's
a guy that's going to look at things and
he's going to make sure he analyzes it
properly and he feels very strongly
about doing what he did and what we did
as an organization so yes I think back
then I would have said that but as we've
as we've been interacting with Michael
here and there over the last probably
year or two I realized that there's a
real bond there and so what where do you
think this can lead because I know
Michael wants to be involved with the
team in a way coaching uh what do you
think this can lead to a greater
relationship between the franchise and
Michael Thomas I don't I don't
necessarily know from a franchise
standpoint I know that Arthur of course
Arthur's very successful businessman and
has a number of businesses so I'm sure
they'll continue to talk about you know
you know if there's any any sort of
involvement at some level I don't know
necessarily from from from an
organization football side I I don't I
haven't I've not heard anything about
that at this point Thomas de metro
Falcons general manager joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show Don Terry poll
that's another piece of news this week
made 125k by making weight it is that
truly an effective way to get guys in
shape do you think Thomas put a price
tag on it I do I think it I think it is
I think you know we don't think that
much about it in today's world work we
have a lot of really athletic guys here
as you know that stands stands approach
in our approach here and so we really
don't have that that much of an issue
our situation with Ontario's
you know he was 55 probably he was
pretty he's a pretty big 355 that is he
was pretty big big guy as you know and
we're more of a one gap scheme he's a
heck of an athlete when you watch him
move out there between 2 45 and 35 I
mean it is really impressive so we
really like our guys to be as lean as
they can without losing the power and
the girth that they need and we're
really excited where he is right now it
is effective for us to keep him in that
role you know and that in that mode of
being that weight that's where he's
going to be the most effective for us
and as you know this is a cross road
season for him we got him on a one-year
deal and we're really excited to see
where he is at this point so how do you
choose the weight you talk about with
the coaching staff and figure out that
you can't with a number and it goes
right in the contract is the agent then
come back and then go ten pounds higher
I mean seriously is there is there a
back and forth on something like that
that's a great question usually what it
is is it's a head coach in the general
manners we'll sit down with our athletic
performance people and we'll talk about
ideal weights we kind of knew where we
thought after watching him a lot video
wise you know and in his games where we
thought he would be effective we never
wanted them to do something unrealistic
like trying to get down to 320 or 310 we
knew it was going to be within you know
20 or something pounds and that's kind
of where our focus was it wasn't that
difficult it really does come down to
the head coach in the general manager
discussing it and usually an agent will
chime in the only time the agent will
have an issue is when it's unrealistic
right they want to make sure that this
their player has an opportunity to make
you know next a few bucks and and
hopefully benefit the team speaking of
agents I mean Devonta Freeman agent
spoke out during the Superbowl and you
know I'm sure that didn't sit well with
the organization and now here we are
getting set to go to the break and
Devonta Freeman still in a walky or do
you plan on addressing this in training
camp at all Thomas I mean yes I mean our
rich our desire is like we've done with
a number of our you know pillar players
over the years I mean we did it with
Matt we did it with Julio you know we're
we're big believers in making sure that
going into camp our goal would be to be
a pro tching this going into camp it
would be nice to have it done before
training camp starts
if not hopefully continued to work on it
through the preseason and and finalize
it is something you know we like him a
lot
I think he's you know he's what he
represents us well right he's a very
urgent runner he's fast he's quick
twitch he runs you know with a again
appropriately angry what does he call it
disrespectful way in the right way of
course and you know that's what we're
looking for here so we really would like
to him to be here for years to come and
we're confident we can get it done well
in terms of you know what's being
discussed in the National Football
League right now I know he's not a
member of your team Odell Beckham jr.
he's got a couple of years left on his
deal levy on Bell as being franchise
tagged right now when he came out of
Michigan State in 2013 what is the
philosophy in NFL front office's why it
is for most players a non-starter to
discuss a new contract when there's more
than one year left on the deal Thomas
we've we've had a lot of conversations
about that because there were waves of
people in the past and some people we
all know are somewhere in the business
some aren't in the business they thought
get the deals done two and three years
early in the end you save more money I
am a big believer in quite honestly in
today's NFL we are much more a win-win
negotiation approach it is not trying to
get one over on the team or get one over
on the player that's not what we're
looking for we want our players to be in
a good spot so that they're not of
course moaning about not getting
rewarded and paid properly of course we
want to make sure that we're not we're
not being taken advantage of so we're
really big on focusing on the market and
the best way to focus on the market is
with one year left you start doing it
two and three years out our feeling is
on it rich respectfully to the people
that can do it and there are
opportunities to do it by the time their
contract comes up again very rarely are
they living out that contract and within
two years or talking about another
contract and if you're what you know
that becomes an issue of course because
they are no longer happy with the
contract they did two years out or three
years out the other thing is the players
who aren't getting the same treatment
they feel shunned and then it
creates a dissension within the locker
room so there are multi layers to this
our big belief is being consistent and
when you're consistent within our
organization with your negotiating and
your approach it seems to really do well
at least in our experience here it
usually though sometimes the quarterback
is the exception Matt Ryan signed
through 2018 are you are you already
looking down the road for a 2019 right
now where he's an unrestricted free
agent Thomas yeah I think I think
quarterbacks can can be looked at that
way at times um we have of course where
we're looking at him we factor him in on
a lot of our moves and you know we're
again in the process of looking at
Devonta Freeman of course as we just
mentioned there are other people on a
roster that you know are going to be you
know big-ticket guys coming up soon
we're always factoring in where our
quarterback will be and whether we do
that next year or the year after or
whatever it is he's going to be a big
part of how we're putting together our
long-term plan of course so sometimes
that can happen of course with the
quarterback I do understand that but I
don't want to influence anything but is
it possible when you have these
conversations you put in the contract he
must refer to himself as the natural
which is my nickname for him and not
Maddie ice can you put that in writing
for me in his conscious right we'll try
you know I was even thinking there was
one day you were going to send a you
know t-shirt here something that he
could you know make sure that he's
trumpeting your nickname because it is
the best not the best one that's ever
been created Thank You Thomas I would do
it but I don't believe him he's too nice
a guy and he's one of those guys who's
probably the worst liar in the world
because I don't believe him that he
really likes it
I don't believe him he's not a good liar
that's for sure he fidgets and he's not
a good liar I agree with you now Thomas
what you get last question for you here
okay this is very this could be the most
important question I've asked you you
you've watched me blossom as a runner
year by year at the combine as you know
I have you you're a man who is a talent
evaluator of the highest order so you've
seen it you know what beats inside and
you know in Atlanta there's a new mascot
for the Braves known as the freeze who
runs people down on the warning track
after getting a 200-foot head start if I
said for charity okay if
I said for charity that I would do this
do you think I could beat the fries yes
or no I we pull tough it'd be tough it'd
be tough but I'd love to see you do it I
think I mean in the name of charity I
mean look you are like you are so
philanthropic in so many ways and I know
you're such a sulfur-sulfur person
soulful person and look the reality is
when I watch you and how you evolve have
evolved as a sort of fleet of foot track
man I'm really impressed and I think you
continue to get better as you age like a
fine wine violin or whatever it is I
mean you can't impress me so I'm I'm
looking forward to seeing you in that
setting let's just put it that way and
after will reward you appropriate okay
Brockman new poll question at Rich Eisen
show who's a worse liar Matt Ryan or
Thomas I'm in traffic on it and we can
definitely turn it up put that who's
worse at lying
oh my god all I know it is a highlight
of my combine to watch that I actually
stay around in our sleep you see
something you run at the end of the
Comba store in conclusion yeah I hear
you Thomas enjoy your downtime you
deserve it okay and we'll chat soon as
always I appreciate you thank you but
that's Thomas Dimitrov the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to